[Musica]
abbiamo un problema
la cultura non è per tutti nel 2019
un'indagine istat ha rilevato che solo
il 30 per cento degli italiani frequenta
almeno una mostra un museo nell'arco
dell'anno vediamola dall'altra parte il
70 per cento degli italiani non visita
neanche un museo una mostra non so se mi
sono spiegata 7 italiani su 10
neanche una volta l'anno neanche in
occasione di una gita scolastica
beh voi potrete pensare è normale non
tanto diciamo che in europa siamo quelli
tra i consumi culturali più bassi
potremmo pensare che però è un
comportamento diffuso generalizzato o
piuttosto c'è un gruppo di buoni
consumatori culturali che ha una
frequentazione intensa per esempio io
dal mio osservatorio vi posso dire che
in piemonte c'è qualcuno che si compra
un abbonamento ai musei
ma chi è questo qualcuno è ha in media
tra i 55 ei 74 anni
al netto di un gruppo di ragazzi di
giovani studenti universitari che godono
di particolari forme di agevolazione è
leggermente più donna appartiene al
gruppo dei grandi consumatori culturali
legge più di dieci libri l'anno va anche
al cinema teatro a vedere un concerto
insomma andava nessuno fa più niente
vive anche in una grande città
metropolitana
insomma sono siamo una nicchia
ora questo fatto che la cultura è fruita
da una porzione tutto sommato piccola
della popolazione ha avuto una
conseguenza abbastanza evidente
nell'anno della pandemia covi di 19
lo abbiamo vissuto sulla nostra pelle
noi operatori culturali che abbiamo
visto la chiusura di biblioteche di
cinema di teatri di musei senza che vi
fosse pressoché alcun dibattito
nazionale
e come se in assenza di flussi turistici
e di scuole soprattutto i miei amati
musei fossero diventati irrilevanti per
la nazione
abbiamo vissuto fino a oggi i musei e le
mostre più come un offerta per i turisti
e per le scuole che non per i cittadini
ora i turisti e le scuole sono un
pubblico importantissimo però il
risultato è stato che in assenza di
turisti non valeva la pena tenere i
musei aperti perché i cittadini non sono
abituati a frequentarli ma come siamo
arrivati a questo punto perché la
cultura non è per tutti perché non siamo
abituati a frequentare i nostri musei
beh io ho provato a darmi qualche
risposta primo a volte è un problema di
infrastruttura solo un museo su quattro
ha una connessione wifi solo un museo su
cinque ha una biglietteria on line il 50
per cento non ha un sito internet è
perché questo è un problema perché li
rende difficili da trovare online ad
esempio o rende difficile sviluppare
iniziative digitali efficienti il quark
o della realtà aumentata tanto per
citarne due
sono tutte tecnologie che hanno bisogno
di un'infrastruttura che funzioni
seconda risposta che mi sono data ea
volte i musei fanno fatica a trasmettere
in maniera chiara il loro messaggio
ditemi se non vi è mai capitato andando
a visitare un museo una mostra di
leggere una didascalia o un pannello
didattico e di non capirci niente
beh a me capita e sono laureata in
storia dell'arte vivo di pane musei da
vent'anni eppure mi capita ogni tanto e
quando succede mi sento a disagio
mi sento in difficoltà irrigidisco ad
esempio o sminuisco il lavoro di
quell'artista usando quella frase così
abusata da essere diventata titolo di un
libro lo sapevo fare anch'io
ancora una risposta e a volte se non
vivo in una grande città penso che non
ci sia un'offerta comoda vicino a me o
se vivo in una grande città penso che ci
sia sempre la coda
ecco voi dovete sapere che da quando
sono uscita dall'università con la mia
bella laurea in storia dell'arte
io mi occupo di partecipazione culturale
cioè di convincere i torinesi ad andare
a vedere i musei di torino e del
piemonte e vi assicuro che i musei
io conosco bene devono essere per tutti
perché possono essere per tutti
ma cosa vuol dire essere per tutti per
me essere per tutti
vuol dire che ognuno di noi deve
sentirsi a suo agio in un museo avere un
museo del cuore dove portare amici e
parenti in visita dove andasse a
prendere un caffè
vuol dire che quando i miei figli
studiano un argomento a scuola che sia
di scienze o di storia
a me viene in mente di portarli in un
museo perché possono toccare
concretamente quello che hanno studiato
ma non è che i musei sono già così e noi
ci stiamo perdendo qualcosa vi racconto
un aneddoto anni fa durante un workshop
legato alla partecipazione culturale
delle famiglie i genitori coinvolti
lamentavano che non ci fossero proposte
per i bambini e portavano invece ad
esempio le attività meravigliose che
avvenivano al prado di madrid e poi
lamentavano che non ci fossero formule
che agevolanti sull'accesso insomma si
lamentavano beh io dovevo stare zitta
naturalmente ascoltavo ma soffrivo
perché quelle proposte c'erano perché i
musei le hanno le proposte didattiche
per i bambini hanno i percorsi tematici
per i bambini pre anziani per i pubblici
più diversi
esiste una formula di abbonamento ai
musei lo abbiamo detto prima che rende
anche accessibile dal punto economico
l'accesso
i musei accolgono le famiglie perché
molti di loro hanno fatto un percorso
per essere family friendly quella fascia
di età tra i 30 e 40 anni poco
rappresentata tra i consumatori
culturali
forse troppo impegnata ad esempio a
mettere su famiglia
pensa che non ci sia un'offerta per lei
in un museo ma sbaglia c'è un'offerta
per lei c'è un progetto meraviglioso che
si chiama nati con la cultura che invita
le famiglie ad andare nei musei coi
bambini in fasce accessibili quindi lo
sono in buona parte i musei
ma cos'altro vuol dire essere per tutti
essere per tutti vuol dire intercettare
gli interessi di tutti e per farlo i
musei si rinnovano continuamente e
costantemente
chi di voi è mai stato in un mot nello
stesso museo a distanza di 45 anni
se siete stati al museo egizio prima del
2015 oggi potreste non riconoscerlo più
lo avrete notato io parlo sempre di
musei ma sono castelli e giardini
fortezze parchi archeologici c'è la
storia e la scienza l'arte antica e
l'arte contemporanea ci sono musei che
raccontano dei pezzi fondamentali della
nostra identità di nazione di città
quanti juventini ci sono in collegamento
siete state muso della juve e c'è anche
il muso del toro lo sapete che al museo
dell'automobile
c'è un atto che ha fatto la parigi
pechino ci sono musei che ci possono far
vivere un'avventura che rappresentano
primati in val chisone al forte di
fenestrelle c'è la scala coperta più
lunga d'europa 4000 gradini
ora io non ci posso credere che nessuna
di queste proposte intercetti il vostro
interesse e vi ho fatto esempi soltanto
di questa regione ma potremmo fare
questo gioco per ogni regione d'italia
e allora sfatiamo il mito
cultura è a disposizione di tutti certo
qualche miglioramento c'è da fare i
musei però mi stanno facendo questi
passi per risolvere quei tre problemi ma
voi fate un passo verso di loro
allora vorrei invitarvi ad amare la
vostra città e la vostra regione come
amate le città e le regioni che andate a
visitare fate quello che fa resta
arrivando a parigi a praga mosca
procuratevi una guida della città anzi
una di quelle mappe dove sono segnalati
monumenti e musei arrivati a casa
prendete una biro e segnatevi luoghi che
avete visto negli ultimi due o tre anni
e poi con un bel evidenziatore
sceglietene 45 da andare a visitare nei
prossimi mesi
diamoci la possibilità di scoprire
lasciamoci coinvolgere e promette temi
che non di rete più i musei sono noiosi
non c'è niente di interessante per me la
cultura e fu e là fuori per tutti la
cultura è per me ed è per voi
la cultura è per tutti perché la cultura
è di tutti diamo del tu alla cultura
grazie
[Applauso]